- Hello, everyone!
So, welcome to another
episode of Unlocking Lily.
It's always been my dream
to be a speaker, and I quit
my day job in order to work and
mentor under Evan full time,
and all of you are coming
along for the ride with me.
(whoosh)
So in every episode, I take
on a different challenge
that really stretch my
comfort zone, all in order
to help me grow as a speaker.
So, my challenge this time
is to take a deep dive
into the three speakers that
I resonated with the most.
So, they are Tony Robbins,
Brene Brown and Simon Sinek.
I'm going to try to
understand, what are the things
that they did to get to where
they are today, as well as
the important lessons that I
learned from each one of them.
Number one is Tony Robbins.
He's an author, speaker, and
a peak performance coach.
(rock music)
So, when Tony Robbins was only
17 years old, he met a man
by the name of Jim Rohn, who
was a motivational speaker.
So when Tony Robbins first got started,
he didn't try to figure
out everything on his own.
Instead, he went and mentored
under Jim Rohn to see
what made Jim so successful,
so that way he could apply
the same actions and same
behavior to himself as well.
- Some of the things Mr. Shoaff taught me,
starting at age 25--
- I had a dear, dear friend
and mentor named Jim Rohn,
who was my teacher when
I was 17 years old.
He's somebody, I sent out
some videos, I'll probably
attach some things to this
video, another one about him,
just to honor him and his
teachings, but he gave me a way
of looking at life that
allowed me to not ask life
to be easier, but to ask that I be better.
He got me to realize that the
secret to life was to work
harder on myself than
my job or anything else,
because then I'd have
something to give people.
And he really shaped me,
and he just passed away,
and I was thinking, wow, I'm
going to be 49 years old,
I met him when I was 17.
Think of the fact that my
journey is just beginning
and think of all the impact
that a just couple ideas had
on my life, and I want to
really continue to do that
for you and anybody you care about, so--
- So, after working and
mentoring under Jim Rohn,
Tony Robbins went on to doing
his own seminars as well.
But he didn't get his actual
breakthrough until he cured
a woman from her lifelong
snake phobia live on stage.
- There's a famous story about
something, I've forgotten
now, but somebody had some
kind of phobia, what was it?
- [Tony] Snake phobia.
- Snake phobia.
(speaking over each-other)
- [Interviewer] --seven years,
and you did it in 15 minutes.
- Yeah, but what made my
career was that I was attacked
by the psychiatrists on the
radio saying you're a liar,
you're charlatan, people like
you should not be allowed
on the radio, you can't do this,
and so, I was a real rebel,
frankly, and I was, like, getting
in his face, saying great,
are you a scientist?
If you are, then test your hypothesis.
Give you me your patient,
I'll be at the Holiday Inn
tomorrow night, so it
was like, this shootout,
and it was like a movie.
He brought her, I wiped it
out, I wrapped the snake
around her, and a phobia is
an uncontrollable physical
response to some stimulus.
Y'know, it's not just fear,
it's shaking, spitting.
At the end, she was totally
fine, he worked on her
for seven years, so that
became my signature,
was to challenge, and then
gradually, I grew, because
I was really just trying to
prove to everybody, and myself
as well, that I was worthy,
rather than, y'know, maturing
a little bit and just knowing
that there are skill sets
that are valuable for everybody.
- So, what Tony Robbins taught
me is that success clues.
Similar to what Tony
Robbins did with Jim Rohn
is what I am doing with
Evan, which is why I quit
my very safe, very comfortable
well-paying day job
to spend full-time hours with Evan.
Even though a lot of our
days are spent not talking
to each-other because we're
working on separate projects,
what I do is I actually study
everything that Evan does.
How does he set up his day?
How does he interact with people?
How does he problem-solve?
And everything else in-between.
Because I'm trying to
look for clues, myself,
and patterns and behaviors,
so that way, I can apply
all of that to myself and
achieve the similar kind
of success that Even has, too.
So, number two is Brene Brown.
She is an author, speaker,
and a research professor.
So when Brene Brown
started out on her journey
as a researcher, she quickly
realized the importance
of having the courage
to show up and be seen.
- Vulnerability is not about winning,
it's not about losing, it's
about having the courage
to show up and be seen.
It's about willingness to say, look,
I don't have all the answers.
This is daring greatly for me.
I'm wearing false eyelashes.
And my biggest fear, when
they put 'em on, was like,
am I going to get halfway
through this thing and be like,
like I can't do it?
- If you do, just rip the whole thing off.
That's happened to me before.
Just rip 'em both off and there you are.
Naked before the world.
- [Brene] You may see it here today.
Yeah, so, I mean, I think,
people tell me all the time,
I don't want to be vulnerable,
I don't want to do this,
'cause I can't bear this.
And I think being
vulnerable feels dangerous,
and I think it feels scary,
and I think it is terrifying,
but I don't think it's as
dangerous, scary or terrifying
as getting to the end of
our lives and wondering,
what if I would have shown up?
What if I would've said, I love you back?
- [Oprah] Yeah.
- So that, to me, is
what daring greatly is.
- So Brene Brown continued to
teach, as well as do research
at the University of Houston.
But it wasn't until her popular TEDx talk,
The Power of Vulnerability,
that received over 30 million
views, that catapulted her into
the star that she is today.
- What underpinned this shame,
this I'm not good enough,
which, we all know that
feeling, I'm not blank enough.
I'm not think enough, rich
enough, beautiful enough,
smart enough, promoted enough.
The thing that underpinned
this was excruciating
vulnerability, this idea
of, in order for connection
to happen, we have to
allow ourselves to be seen,
really seen.
And you know how I feel
about vulnerability,
I hate vulnerability, and so,
I thought, this is my chance
to beat it back with my measuring stick.
I'm going in, I'm going
to figure this stuff out,
I'm going to spend a year, I'm
going to totally deconstruct shame,
I'm going to understand
how vulnerability works,
and I'm going to outsmart it.
So I was ready, and I was really excited.
As you know, it's not
going to turn out well.
(audience laughs)
You know this.
- So what Brene Brown taught
me is that I need to have
the courage to show up.
There's so many things
that I'm afraid to do,
because I'm concerned that
people are going to judge me
and criticize me, but the reality
is, I want to be a speaker.
I want to be able to inspire
people through my work,
which means I need to get
outside of my comfort zone
and do the brave things and be courageous.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go into the biggest
intersection in Toronto,
Yonge-Dundas Square,
and film in front of everyone.
Even though I am so scared even
thinking about it to do it.
But I need to do it
because I need to be brave
and have the courage to show up.
Number three is Simon Sinek.
He's an author, leadership
guru and a speaker.
So, Simon Sinek first
started out by owning his own
business, but he completely
lost passion for what he did,
which caused him to look
inward and to find his why.
- And I realized, I knew what I did.
I was good at it.
And I knew how I did it,
I could tell you what was
different or special about
the way I did things.
But I couldn't tell
you why I was doing it.
That was the missing piece,
you have to have all three.
I became obsessed with
this thing called the why.
I figured out how to find
my why, and it restored
my passion to levels I had
never experienced before.
And more importantly, I
figured out how to help others
find theirs, and I did
what anyone would do.
When you discover something
beautiful, you share it
with your friends, and
my friends started making
crazy life changes themselves.
And they started finding
happiness and passion
that they'd never experienced before.
It was me solving my own
problem that happened
to help others solve it for them, too.
- When Simon Sinek found his
why, he started helping friends
and friends of friends
find their whys as well.
But it wasn't until his
extremely popular TEDx talk,
Start With Why, which has
over 32 million views to date,
that launched his career into
becoming a bestselling author,
as well as a consultant to major
companies around the world.
- But if you don't know
why you do what you do,
and people respond to you do what you do,
then how will anybody, how
will you ever get people
to vote for you or buy something for you,
or more importantly, be loyal,
and want to be a part of
what it is that you do?
Again, the goal is not just
to sell to people who need
what you have, the goal
is to sell to people
who believe what you believe.
- What Simon Sinek taught
me is that I need to start
with my why.
And my why is to inspire
people to be extraordinary.
So, going forward, all
the meetings I have,
all the interactions I have,
all the phone calls I have,
I'm going to start with my why.
So, over the next few weeks,
I'm going to be taking on
different challenges based
on the lessons that I learned
from Tony, Brene and Simon.
But, Evan just gave me
a surprise challenge.
I'm going to participate
is my first corporate gig,
which means that all of
you are going to come
behind the scenes in my
first corporate event.
So the quesh of the day
is, what is that one lesson
you learned from someone you look up to?
It could be an entrepreneur
that you saw on Evan's channel,
it could be a teacher, it
could be a family member.
I would love to know what that lesson is.
Please leave it in the comments below,
and I will join in on the discussion.
So, I want to thank you guys
for watching, and I actually
have a special shout-out for Pavo Luevano.
So, Pavo wrote in my last
episode that this editing
is ten times better than any TV show.
Honestly, Pavo, thank you
so much for the kind words,
and it's actually our
fabulous editor, Christina,
that does an amazing
job with all our videos.
So, Christina, high five
for a job well done.
- Hey, Lily!
And thank you, Pavo.
- So thank you so much for
watching, but more importantly,
being on this journey with me.
When I first started
out, I really didn't know
what to expect.
But all the love and encouragement
just kept on pouring in
that gave me the courage to keep going on,
and I couldn't ask for a better community
than Believe Nation to be part of this.
So, once again, thank
you, thank you so much,
I am so grateful, and I
will see you very very soon.
(whoosh)